aumenta la tensión electoral en Estados
Unidos a tan solo un mes de las
elecciones de medio término en las que
se renovarán las dos cámaras del
congreso las calles de diferentes
ciudades del país se llenaron de
manifestantes marchando a favor del
aborto
necesitamos unirnos y luchar contra lo
que está sucediendo a través del proceso
gubernamental y lo que estamos pensando
es que debemos apoyar a las mujeres
estadounidenses para que tomen
decisiones por sí mismas
desde la victoria de Donald Trump en
2016 anualmente se realiza la marcha de
las mujeres en todo el país y este año
tuvo un objetivo claro manifestar el
rechazo la histórica anulación de
robertsway la cual puso fin a la
protección del derecho al aborto a nivel
federal y dio como resultado que 13 de
los 50 estados ya prohíban la
interrupción del embarazo los demócratas
han hecho del aborto un tema central
para su campaña de las elecciones de
medio término de este 8 de noviembre los
resultados de los comicios decidirán si
el partido el presidente Joe biden
conservará el poder en el congreso o si
los republicanos logran quitárselo
con las próximas elecciones de mitad de
término es de Vital importancia a
recordarle a la gente que salga y para
que de esta manera podamos preservar
nuestras libertades básicas y codificar
con suerte codificar la igualdad
matrimonial y cualquier otro de los
demás
Además del aborto la economía también es
un tema fundamental para las elecciones
que se acercan en un momento donde la
inflación supera el 8% y los precios de
los combustibles han ido aumentando a
niveles históricos